hello everybody welcome to
the lab roots webinar today we are going
to talk about
from the data to biological insight
using kaijen omixot and kaijen ipa
and specifically for the single cell
sequencing of a normal human liver
so the objective to explore the cellular
landscape of the human liver in that
particular case but it could be true for
any type of tissue or organs is to
understand
what cells comprises a normal human
liver
so how many distinct cell types are in a
representative liver sample
what gene expression markers best
distinguish
cell type within the liver do publish
cell type signature correspond to the
liver cell clustered
by expression similarities we can also
try to understand what is the biology
shared
between these clusters what molecular
pathways
and biological processes are highlighted
in the clusters
what transcriptional programs underpin
each cell type
and also with our technology we can try
to discover
hidden biology by comparing that
specific single cell
analysis of all the different clusters
to a set of
over 60 thousand curated analysis
so the agenda today will be to describe
for you
what is the kaizen meaning of sample to
insight
we're in second part to talk about the
kai genomics of
lens how do we curate the single cell
data set
then we are going to explore from the
omics offline to array studio which is
the
software that do the data analysis
where the data is going to be processed
then
from array studio to kaijan ipa we're
going to send a data
to discover and highlight the biology of
the different cell types in the liver
then we will try to explore hidden
biology and i will explain
what it means then we will bring some
conclusion
the casual kaizen sample to insight
it's a very important notion that equip
any researcher and scientist in the lab
from the sample collection and
stabilizations to
the interpretations and today we are
going to talk about
two specific or three specific software
that we have developed
over the years kaizen omix soft ls suite
for the data analysis and cajon ipa
or kaizen ingenuity pathway analysis and
kaijen or mix offline explorer
for the biological interpretation
the kaijan knowledge base
indeed powers the ipa engineer patrol
analysis
and we do that because we have
accumulated literature findings over the
last 20 years and all these findings
that are manually
manually curated or using a spec
expert assist findings we have
structured them in the
knowledge base model knowledge base so
every content and every findings as we
describe that
are well structured in a way that the
software ipa is able to retrieve
based on your expression data very key
and important findings that is pertinent
to that data
the content of ipa is based on what we
call a finding this is a typical finding
and what's key to remember here is the
content
is contextual and have direction of
effect in other words we capture
every important
features of the findings in order to
tell us on the right
that the particular gene here nfe2l2
downregulated in a particular
experiment when it's connected to that
gst m3 and we know the connection we
know the
interaction between these two genes we
can predict the effect of that down
regulation on f52
on that gene in that case predicted to
be inhibited
and all of that is due to the context
and all the important information
direction of effect on the gene
expression
mutation tap if it's enough stream of
dance engine what type of tissue
what type of species and so on
so all these 7.1 million findings help
us to understand
what's going on and to predict the
pattern of
activity
particular case we have developed today
it's a come from a public data set
put on the ncbi geo and it's about
a paper that has been published in
nature communication in 2018 by
mcparland and its group
and the title was single cell rna
sequencing of human liver reveals
distinct
and hepatic macrophage populations
so they have proceeded to a single cell
aren't
thick of whole human liver cellular
landscape from liver craft
of five healthy neurological disease
donors
they have a particular procedure they
dissociate the liver tissues in order to
not
kill the cells per person
and they have follow a single cell
sequencing protocol using
10x genomic single cell 3 prime v2
then the sequence on the high seek
illumina 2500
using cell ranger for the pipeline in
our case
we have used the alignment to human b37
using our proprietary aligner or mix of
aligner
and we have quantify using llcm and
proceed to obtain dimension reduction
using this name
so the data which is processing a mix-up
is going to be sent
directly through ipa via a simple
plug-in
it's very easy for biologists like me
you are going to process the data
you send your expression file and in ipa
we are going to interpret the biology
called
dataset and in return we are able to
compare
your own analysis or analyze this to
a set of 60 000 and we'll explain that
in later slides
so a mixed offline processing pipeline
starts with retrieval of
public submitted projects where relevant
to a specific disease have been
submitted to variety of
public resources including ncbi sa
jio areas express
enea and a subset of the human cell at
last
all of that have been curated in a
single cell land pipeline
the key to the omics of curation is in
fact the collaborative process between
the biological curator
and the bioinformaticians and you can
see here there's multiple steps
between these two pipelines the
interaction
is essential the curator will perform a
number of
metadata extraction and curation steps
including automated metadata extraction
from submitted geoproject
and in addition single cell specific
metadata fields will be extracted
as well from the project and from the
paper
that will be followed by the curation of
the project and the paper to apply
very controlled vocabulary columns that
can identify
key statistical comparison and identify
as well expect a number of cell types
the data processing team downloads the
raw data from the fastq
file using the advice from the biologist
the writer it defines the pipelines
to analyze this data depending on if you
have
a umi or non-umi type of data i will
explain that in the next slide
then the full data processing pipeline
resulting in quantification of the genes
will be obtained
using the advice of the biological
curator identifying the number of
different clusters expecting
the disney analysis
the data processor will do an initial
analysis
and dimension reduction of the sample to
identify it
and to generate a t-sne plot that will
allow us to identify
initial number of proposed cell clusters
or cell types
these data will be shared back with the
curator
to review and identify the proposed cell
types and how this compares
to the original paper if there is
any discrepancy then the
additional advice will be sent to the
data processor
to rerun the this knee and identify the
proper number of clusters to best
represent what has been founded indeed
in the original paper
the data processor will run a
differential expression analysis
using thorat to identify the top
differentially regulated genes
between the different clusters and the
cell specific signature can be used
to identify cell types and different
expressions as well
these data are entering to the len
repository
and this is an example of some of the
source
for the dataset processing and metadata
metadata curation
the biologist relies on
it includes gene expression of neighbors
submissions
and sometimes the detail from the
methods of the papers and
result papers
you can see here there is a variety of
different single cell library
preparation technology
that all requires different methods for
the pre-processing and the analysis of
the data
for example you have umi
unique molecule molecular identifier
best technology that will use the three
prime tagging of unique molecule to
minimize
the amplification bias artifacts and
then there is also
non-umi based technology that tends to
measure
a smaller number of cells that have a
higher coverage
and they don't have the three prime bias
so the manual curations of the single
data from a domain expert is key
right and this is are some of the
resources
that are used by the object source
curators to analyze single cell data
the source paper the gene expression
which you have that on the submissions
which has many columns that can be
extracted
to the project level the sample
level metadata that are submitted for
each individual biological samples
the actual sample data files
which are compiled into metadata
framework and control for certain key
terms such as
tile type sources these sources are
compiled into a metadata
matrix to allow you to find a sample
that are of interest for you
in addition to the geo-based submission
additional metadata are extracted from
the paper itself to help
advise the curation of the metadata and
to advise the bioinformatician
in their analysis of the data
they are automatically extracted
metadata columns
that are then formatted to meet a mix of
curation standard using control
vocabularies
and formatting with additional
information extracting from
the publication there is additional
manual curation based on the disease
therapeutic area
and more focused disease each individual
subject
disease state and the tissue from which
the data came
in addition as available any sort of
recommended metadata such as
cell type side entities and treatment
status and so forth
are also applied to the individual
samples and
are all applied with the control
vocabulary
in addition to the automatic and
manually extracted key metadata
there is also additional project
specific metadata
that can also be included into each of
these
single cell project
animal strain land specific
this is specific information depending
on the specific therapeutic
area that could be analyzed and any
platform specific information that would
be relevant to the biologist
and interpreting these such as the
library
preparation and the presence for
instance of ercc spikins
for normalization
again what is key here is the
interactivity and iterative curation
between
the biologists and the bioinformatician
to have the best
possible single cell line project the
most
reliable the most faithful to
the original paper
so this is particularly important for
the generation of the dimensional
reduction plot such as the tisny that
you can see
on the right based on the source paper
the biologist advised the
bioinformatician about which individual
samples
should be including in a particular
disney analysis
as well as the expected number of
cluster which
approximates the number of cell types
expected to be found in this particular
analysis
the bayern partition ran then runs an
initial tc analysis including k-means
clustering to identify the predicted
cell cluster
these data are written to the biologists
to review the disney result
then adjust the number of cluster
settings to match the publish
result as best as possible to make sure
that samples or cells are not being
divided
arbitrarily then the bioinformatician
runs
disney pipeline to match the publication
an additional curation may be added by
the biologist
to help identify what the individual
cell
types are using an annotation of the
paper of
the individual gene signature for cell
types and domain knowledge
of the biologists and then the final
project is submitted for publication
into the land
so within the land framework that you
see
here the way you would find a new
project of interest is simply to
browse the available project showing
here
on this bar plot you can see that in
this case we've broken down the
different project based
on the main tissue of origin we are
looking at liver
here for our cases
we have also project metadata
of interest when you find a project of
interest
you can actually click download
that project into your server project
and the full package
will be in your project folder
that's what we have done in that case
so we have uploaded that specific
project the gse 115469
it's a umi project it's about the lever
single cell level
single cell over normal human liver
sorry
and what is put into download into our
server project
is all these files three computed files
for biologists like me
it's very easy and it's very quick
so you get the cell curation type
you get the quantification table
you get the differential expression in
the inference report
you get the cell clustering pattern you
are going to discover the disney
you have also the top gene markers using
sarat here
and you have a set of curated project
information
such as i have described the cluster
project and sample metadata
that allows you based on these
heavily created projects to
simplify and this is what i've done in
my case to
some biological cluster of interest so
based on the k-means 20
that i've been presenting in that paper
i have
for the sake of that webinar simplified
to set of 12 cluster with
some namings alphabeta t cells
cholangiocyte erythroid hepatocyte and
so forth
in that screenshot you are going to see
that we use serat to
obtain the gene markers and we can also
using
samsara to detect the highly variable
gene between the clusters
so from that step here from which you
have downloaded from the single cell and
project
to your own um customized analysis if
you wish
it's extremely simple because you rely
on the cluster
cell type that has been predefined
previously
so this is what the first kiss knee
based on the k-means 20
was obtained after creating that single
cell
analysis of a normal human lever and
that match exactly what the paper has
found
clusters for hepatocytes for a doterra
search
and from that you can actually obtain
circ test which is equivalent to an
inference report basically a
differential expression profile in which
you can compare
one versus the other clusters or two
versus the other cluster
or 19 versus the other clusters and for
each of them
you will have a 4 change value a log to
transform a p-value and fdr values
that report it's extremely
easy to get and you send that to apm
but as i said because the curation has
been
so well done i can even go further
and to define my own biological clusters
and here this is a representation of the
t-sne
based on the cluster cell type
and that match pretty much what the
paper is saying
for the argument today i have simplified
the five
cluster found in hepatocyte as one
the alpha beta cells and many authors
that are described here so two set of
type of cells in the liver there's the
parenchymal
which are the peptocytes per se and the
non-parenchymal which are
basically the immune cells that has been
discovered
in that paper
same as previously i could create an
inference report basically
an expression profile using serra to
define
highly variable gene and top gene
markers and i would like to compare each
of the
previous cluster biological cluster that
i found
for each of them i could get a
comparison hepatocyte
versus others i can set some features of
interest minimum observation per gene
three minimum of genes per cell 200
and so on doing that you obtain these in
the inference
folder this type of compiles
hepatocyte versus servers hepatic stereo
adversary servers
and many others
so this is exactly what i have proceed
i wanted to look and understand when you
compare
one cell type versus the others
what are we going to obtain in terms of
biology and that should tell us a lot
about the liver this is what we have
done
so we have set all these different 12
clusters
and compared to the set of orders
hepatocyte versus the rest
plasma b cell versus derived and so on
for each of these comparisons we can get
a volcano plot
you can tell here on the right the
upregulated gene
in that case in the hepatocytes and on
the left which are supposed to be green
the down related genes in the hepatocyte
versus orders
that report can be sent directly to ipa
but before doing that
we have another feature which is really
cool we are going to use the scatter
color view
to visualize gene expression across the
cluster themselves
to do that we are going to use the
design table which has been provided
when you download the project
you are going to select the table data
the cell mapped q1 score
you are going to extract the v1 v2
coordinates
and add that to the design table
here this is the cells tissue
the state and the v1 v2 coordinate
because of that i'm able to now
visualize
the expression of one particular gene
in that is me and this is the case here
i selected the tnfs f12
which is a cytokine ligand for tweak r
and that is expressed in the liver as
you can see
but specifically it's expressing the
lymphocytes apparently
in some endothelial cells and some
macrophages
the group of hepatocytes it's a little
bit weak the expression is weaker
but we have another tool as well
when you have kaizen ipa and you obtain
a gene view
and you select that particular gene you
can ask the questions
what is the expression of that genes in
different tissues
to do that to obtain that image here
we use a link that sent us the
information to land
explorer land explorer is a web-based
version
of a mix of land it's very easy to use
and in one click in that case i was able
to look
in blueprint b-38 which is a type of
land
on specifically normal immune cells
where tnfs 12 is expressed and you can
tell
in one click that gene is expressed
big time in a peripheral blood and you
see other tissues much less in the liver
this is a log2 transfer so that
information from the scatter
follower views you can actually expand
that and understand what is the
expression of bad genes in
all the tissue using the link from ipa
to land explorer
it's very easy to do
serat i told you identifies
top epitome marker genes and here i
selected nine of them
and this is the group of hepatocyte
which is highlighted here
the top right many of you will recognize
these genes hp vtn and many others
you can do that as well as for the
copper cells for the example
these are the four marker that has been
identified in the paper
clearly we match exactly what the paper
is saying
that is using the sarat
you can also identify highly variable
genes between the clusters
in fact we like to identify genes that
are highly expressed in some
cell type and lowerly expressed in other
subtypes
and i'm going just to give you two
examples today stat mean
one and cd52 and here this is the
representations
using sarat as well of the expression
variation of expression of that
particular stat mean or cd52
in the different cluster that we have
identified so you can see
there is a high variability that can be
used for further understanding
what's going on in that labor
i told you the data is being processed
in
uh for mixoff the project
sent to arrest suite which is the ad
analysis processor over mixer
and now you can send the data directly
to ips and ipa is the
power tool that
helps you understand what is the biology
in your dataset
so we are using an api that basically
send the information of the dataset
to ipa in which you can eventually
set even the analysis describe what's
going on
set your cutoff and send that to ips
so once you are in ipa the analysis is
done here this is the pattern pathocyte
versus
others we set up some fortunes some
p-value
this is just a screenshot of the summary
of the core analysis what we call core
analysis
and basically we give you the top
canonical pathways
the top upfront regulator and i will
define for you what it is later and many
other informations
so let's go to the core of the
data itself so this is a single cell
and a thick sequencing of normal human
livers
and it does reveal cell
specific canonical pathways here i have
established
a comparison using the comparison
analysis in ipm
we are using the canonical pathways
features and we compare them
in all these different clusters
hepatocytes are on that first column
and all the other clusters are here
on the left i've looked at the metabolic
pathway first person
and on the right have a look at the
signaling pathways
just looking at that comparison it gives
you an idea
of what is the role of the liver there's
effectively
a liver specificity in metabolism
function
a lot of the functions are predicted to
be highlighted
orange will give you the prediction
pattern of
activity blue of inhibitions
so in the hepatocytes you see a lot of
the canonical pathways here
i'm going to show you in the next slide
that are predicted to be activated
and some of the signaling pathways are
predicted to be inhibited
inversely a lot of the metabolic
pathways are
not activated they are inhibited in many
of the
immune cells that has been discovered in
that
single cell sequencing but they are
activated
for signaling pathways
in that cases so a lot of pathways
related to
t-cells cells dendritic cells and k
cells are effectively predicted to be
activated
so these help you to understand the
immunobiology
and the metabolic functions of the liver
per se just
one comparison can give you that but let
me explore a little bit
i'll show you here four canonical
pathways that are predicted to be
activated
by polysis fatty beta
oxidation cholesterol biosynthesis
glutathione methadide detoxifications
and we know the hepatocytes perform
important roles in the normal liver
and these metabolic pathways are all
predicted to be activated in hepatocytes
versus and they are inhibited in the
limb and liver
so we can ask questions which is a
feature that has been released
in kaizen ip at the end of march of
looking
particular pathways of interest that has
been predicted to be activated
as i mentioned in the previous slide and
ask the question
where that pathway is predicted to be
activated when you
bring thousands of data right
so from the omics of land we have
gathered
a set of 60 000 comparison expression
and put that in
our database in ipa and now we can see
where fatty acid beta oxidation is
predicted to be activated
this is called an activity plot
all these dots represent a data set
on the x app six we have the z score on
the right
predicted to be activated on the left
predicted to be limited
and this is based on the log p value
so the higher level on the most right
the most
significantly predicted to be activated
on the left
higher level the more significantly
predicted to be inhibited
just for the visualization i look at
that point this is a particular data set
it was about
a high-fat diet and this is a
treatment where you use a p paragonist
in specific conditions
so let's explore where fatty acid beta
oxidation
is mainly predicted to be activated
so we use a tool that will basically
try to give us an idea of enrichment of
keywords
right that's what we try to gather
so i have selected on that previous
slide a set of
data sets that will give me a z-score
superior to so we have a very high
confidence that the fatty acid
[Music]
oxidation pathways is going to be
predicted to be activated
and we are going to look at a set of
dataset that has been imported from
omixoft that came from disease land
and on columns it seems to be a little
bit complex right now but
this island and on colon are a set of
comparison expressions
indifferent oncological or many
other type of diseases we have gathered
them normalize them created them send
that to ap and now we can compare
the profile of prediction between our
own data set
and these data
so i have selected filters score 2
specifically in discipline and colon and
now we are going to look
when we evaluate the metadata where are
the
terms that comes the most that will give
us an idea
in what type of data set
fabo is predicted predictably to be
activated and in fact when you look at
that
fibroactivity significantly enriched
with high-fat diets key terms and p
paragonist pre-paragonista
anti-diabetics
these p par nuclear receptors are indeed
involved
in the control of metabolism and
inflammation in metabolic
disease and immunity so just looking at
the enrichment
of keywords in coming from the metadata
that have been processed from a micron
we can tell you that
fatty acid beta oxidation pathways are
predicted to be activated
when you have that context of high-fat
diet
or usage of pre-paragonist that can give
you some clue
in that hepatocytes we have looked at
the top gene markers
and just looking at these 16
genes here with their expression in
uniquely
hepatocytes all of the genes here
organize many of them
it encompassed so many functions that
the liver is doing
particular metabolism of cholesterol
triglycerides lipoprotein
fatty acid also transport
coagulation blood vessel formations
fibrosis inflammatory processes and many
others
so when you have
a thorax to object markers you can
extract meaningful
information by going back from omixoff
scatter color view and ipa the gene view
where you will
generate a lot of new knowledge
let's look at particular cell type
that we have compared to the rest poland
your site
and when you have the scatter color view
you identify the top gene marker app
campus which
fits exactly what the paper has
described this is the cholangiocyte a
small
number of cells very well identified and
characterized we can
try to understand what would they do
we know these cells are normally
quiescent in the liver
and in fact they do respond to injurious
or stress
by enhancing their proliferation
here this is one of the top canonical
pathways
that has been predicted by ipa to be
inhibited so we're talking about the
pathways
called acute phase response signaling
and that pathway is predicted to be
inhibited
and in fact indicating the absence of
stress we are
looking at a single cell sequencing from
a normal human liver
that pathway should be predicted to be
inhibited this is a strong p-value a
strong disco
so in a normal situation the
cholangiocyte
should not trigger that particular
pathway and that is confirmed by
the kaijen ipa analysis
now we would like to understand in very
simple term what will be
between called the transcriptional
program what what is driving
of that particular expression file
and here i'm just giving you a
screenshot of a comparison of
what we call upstream regulators
to simplify transcriptional programs
that are the drivers
and here this is a hierarchy called
clustering of all
the different comparisons hepatic
stellite versus order
on the tl cells versus others and many
other situations here hepatocyte versus
and we are going to represent
here the pattern of activity of that
particular gene vgf
in each of these different clusters
so what you need to remember is the
orange color
indicates to you a pattern of
activations
a blue pattern of inhibitions
so vgfa is the most predicted to be
activated
in liver sinus endothelial cells here
has the higher z-score and highest
p-value
let's look at what's happening in that
liver sinus endothelial cells we know
they control the tolerance in normal
liver
but they are as well implicated in
angiogenesis in normal
human liver and this is what we need to
see using that vgfa as a driver
so here going back to the scatter polar
view we identify
one of the group of the mondotail cells
by the marker clegg for g plus here
in that particular group we have
identified the gfa as i mentioned in the
previous slide to be predicted to be
activated let's imagine we put
all the genes that are known to be
associated with that vgfa
downstream of it connect it to them
and we can look at what
would be the biological process being
statistically significant the top one
is angiogenesis so that network
indicates what
vgfa is predicted to be activated it's
in orange
based on the pattern of expression of
all the genes you see on that network
and that network drive on geogenesis
app that's very interesting
now let's look at vgfa where is it
expressed
exactly well vgfa is expressed
mainly in hepatocytes group
and almost known in the
endothelial cells that
gives you an idea of a possible
signaling from one cell to another
and that would not have been discovered
if you don't have the two tools to get
the kaijen for mix offline and the
kyogen ipx
let's analyze the copper cells we know
they drive the horse defense the iron
metabolism
and phagocytosis as well as many other
functions in the liver
on the left three scatter color view
that are showing the copper cells marker
that has been identified in the paper as
well cd5l
marco physique 4.
all of these markers are having a role
in
immune functions
we have looked at the same idea we have
compared all these different clusters
and look at a particular
abstram regulator called the
transcriptional program if you wish
and we have identify spi-1
the most predicted in the copper cells
here in orange not at
all activity near parasite it's blue
it's inhibited that factor is predicted
to be activated
in the copper cells and you can tell
here when you look at the scatter
color view where it is expressed it's
actually expressed as well in the copper
cells
so that differs from the previous
example where one gene
is not expressed yet drive a
program on another type of cell
and in that case one factor expressed in
the type of cells
and drive the same program within the
same cells
that for cells we know they are involved
in immune responses
and you can see that here i've done the
same
created the network driven by s p
i 1 predicted to be activated when
we grow a disease it's a tool we have in
case an ipa
we look at the most significant function
and immune response of
white cells is are predicted to be
activated so that factor going
up boosts the immune response of
leukocytes
we can detect that in the tucker cells
but we can look also at another type of
factor that was interesting to us
is pfor
p4 is a protein likely supplied by the
blood
and activate targets in the cochlear
cells
pf4 has the highest prediction of
activations in the copper cells
much lower in the other group inhibited
in the hepatic cell
and non-existent in the other set of
clusters that we see here
pf4 is not expressed in the normal human
liver you can see that
absence of a dot in
any of the cluster type yet pf4 is
predicted to be active in the copper
cells
so one question was
if you put the target of pa4 which are
represented here by these
immune proteins cxl3 xcl8 and many
others
you connect them through pf4 because
based on the pattern of expression of
these genes we have
identified that p4 is predicted to be up
we have asked the question let's connect
the most
significant canonical pathways that we
have defined previously
well trem one is in orange and hepatic
fibrosis signaling is
predicted to be activated as well
so we know that pf4 factor
which is predicted to be activated in
copper cells
can drive the hepatic fibrosis and
launch some part of the innate immunity
through time one as well
so you can associate lack of expression
prediction of activation of a particular
factor
and a set of canonical pathways via a
set of genes
connected you can look also the
predicted activity
using the z-score of these two different
factors pf4 and spa one when you overlap
that
on the testing that's an exercise that
we have done here so you can
quickly see that for pf4 hepatocytes
there is not even a disc
we don't know but from some other cells
like the nk cells
it's uh the gamma the t cells it's
predicted to be
inhibited and same for spi-1
spl1 is predicted to be inhibited in
hepatocyte
strongly activated in gamma dental
t-cells and some other
macrophageal compressors
we can also discover the ps4 expression
using the
mix of land explorer we have a look at
the gtex which
look at the 51 normal human tissues
pf4 is heavily expressed in the blood
not in the liver and we can specifically
look at the expression in normal
immune cells looking at blueprint b38
alpha beta t cells are strongly
expressing that particular molecule
much less for the other group of cells
including
m1 m2 microphones all of that
is realized by going to the gene view
in ipky and ipa pa4 clicking on the link
to gtx or to blueprint extremely easy
very simple we have look also at pax 5
which is predicted to be activated in
resident b cells in normal
human liver same
as pfo back five is not expressed at all
in a normal human event
yet we can predict
a strong pattern of activity in the
cluster of b cells versus the others
stronger this score
longest p-value for pac-5 predicted to
be activated in the b-cells
absent or inhibited in other types of
clusters
when you look at the network driven by
pacify and you put
the genes downstream from which we can
predict the pattern of activity of pax
phi and you set all these molecules that
are
upregulated in the b cells or done
regulating in the b cells when you
compare two others
and you put them in all the different
scatter color view
you realize by looking at red circle or
green sequel
and this is the b cells cluster in which
these particular molecules are expressed
and effectively
these sets of molecules are expressed in
the b cells
and these sets of molecules are done
ability not expressing the b cell
so you can go back and forth to a
network of interest
a factor of interest in particular cell
type of interest and
visualize that in the scatter ecology
same we have looked at the
expression in gtex and blueprint
this particular factor heavily expressed
in knives b
cells in mature memory and class switch
b
cells right yet i told you in
in our case in the normal human level we
didn't see
that much of uh if none packs five
expressions
maybe it's due to the fact that these
specific b
cells are not really present we may have
another type of marker to define which
one
but these ones were not probably present
as well
it's heavily expressed in the spleen the
blood and small intestine
using a quick view on gtex as well
we were interested in another factor
that were
this time activated in three cell type
alpha beta gamma delta and nk cells
the immune cells per se that are
revealed
in that single cell sequencing and nlc5
actually play a role in cytokine
responses and antiviral
immunity and it's predicted to be
activity that you can
tell by the orange color in all these
three types and strongly inhibiting in
the hepatocyte
if you look at the expression of an lfc5
in the scatter color view you realize
effectively the presence of alpha beta
t cells here some macrophages some more
detail cells a little bit
we have asked the same question as for
the pathways nlf is predicted to be
activated
but in what situations can can looking
at 60 000
dataset tell us anything any insight and
the answer is yes
so here this is a plot that look at
thousand analysis
in which nnfc5 is predicted to be
activated
this core superior r2 or predicted to be
inhibited this core inference minus two
we can look at a specific metadata here
this
alpha versus control in a fibro
sarcoma type of experiment well let's
explore in our case
where we think that nrc5 is expressed
we are going just to set this score
superior r2
so we're asking the question show me the
enrichment
of keywords in which that particular
analysis 5 is predicted to be activated
same as before we're going to evaluate
the metadata give us an idea
well not surprising when you look at the
case case treatment
that an elsify is predicted to be
activated when the treatment is
interferon gamma
or interferoalpha and in response to
viral infection
that gives you the notion that that
compound is pretty important in immune
response in general
and to confirm that you look at the set
of analysis in which that
compound is predicted to be inhibited to
quickly
go about if you evaluate the metadata
with setting certain z-score realize
that that compound
is inhibited when you have an acute
respiratory
infection in that particular case when
you have the chance to
have carrigen ipm you will look that
type of experiment was including
rhinoviruses and
coronaviruses as we know it's a dramatic
situation
right now so that compound is predicted
to be immediate in a case of overall
infections
it can tell us that it's an important
player in immune responses
if you put that compound
on a network as well as interferon gamma
which we know
right now that they are connected based
on the metadata
and we did find a connection in case an
ipa that
ties that interferon to an lc5 and you
put that on a
network all these genes are known to be
downstream of interference
or an lc5 when you put them together and
they are both
predicted to be activated viral
infection going down
so it's a very simple way of expressing
the fact that interferon gamma and lrc5
are actually connected and participate
in the antiviral response in the liver
now i told you many times since the
beginning of that webinar that we have
the possibility of comparing our own
data set we have done let's say
pathocyte versus order b cell versus
two set of sixty thousand other curated
comparison expressions here it's called
analysis match
and that passed to discover
many hidden biology by looking at
other datasets what's going in an other
type can we identify care regulator
pathways
can we get greater insight can we have
confidence in ourselves
and just doing that by comparing to the
rest of the world
so to simplify a thousand of these
comparison expressions that i said
coming from zero tcga
as expressed in my first part of the
talk
have been processed using the same
pipeline and they have been sent
into cash and ipa in a repository and
along with the 7.1 million findings we
have
you can tell you can beat a very strong
biological insight and we can do that
because we can look at
different diseases different tissue
different expressions different erasing
datasets
so let's go to what we know right now we
compare
gamma data t-cells versus orders and we
have selected
two sets of land called tcga very well
known by everybody and encogio which
encompass
a lot of comparison expression in
oncological situations
and i have to ask the questions
show me in what my gamma delta
t cells normal situations others can
compare to and it does compare to
liver and bile duct cancer liver
it's very strange but
it does compare the canonical pathways
level and the transcriptional level
with some important difference so in
other words
i have a look at the gamma delta t cells
versus other
comparisons and i have the question
what are the other datasets in tcga and
encodio
can compare to a very high level of
similarities for the canonical pathways
prediction
and abstract regulator predictions to my
own dataset
well liver and bile.com cells compare
as i said with some differences and the
differences are here
we have three components one i didn't
mention but just for the argument i show
that
and elsify interferon gamma and tbx21
all of them are involved in human and by
the cancer apparently
all of these compounds are predicted to
be active in the normal human liver
in these gamma delta t cells but you can
tell
when you compare these abstram regulator
program
interferon gamma is the only one to be
predicted to be activated
in these oncological situations liver
cancer
by the cancers and many others so it's
very interesting because
when you have the gamma delta t cells
these three compounds in the normal
situations with that
viral insert or
other type of injury or other type of
disease like cancers
these three components are credited to
be activated
but nlrc5 and tbx21 are
not predicted to be activity they are
not even present apparently
in these liver concerns by the cancers
so that tells us
as an hypothesis that needs to be
validated
to fight this type of disease for
instance you will need
the three components to be predicted to
be activated to
make it work when you have only one well
cancer is still there
we can look also in a land called human
disease what is the expression level
in particular diseases of the liver
these compounds are expressed
tdx-21 interferon and lrc5
and here this is just a very quick
representation uh maybe you don't see
enough but
uh in situation of mafia mario disease
tbx21 is highly expressed
interferon much less and uh nlc5 a lot
so going from that comparison of
abstract regulator from a normal
set uh cell type versus other in a
disease situation
you can also look at the expression of
this particular compound
in a setting that are not relevant to
our casey but
inflammatory disease or other type of
injury so to conclude here
i hope i could explain that we can
identify biological clusters
um easily in our single cell land
project
we have identified many abstract
regulators and biological processes that
are involved in a
cell specific manner we have identify as
well biological cluster that could be
connected to important expression data
in
other datasets such as cancer and other
diseases
to highlight some kind of correlations
and we have also discovered hidden
biology by
understanding the behavior of molecules
pathways
and this is a function across a set of
thousand other comparisons
so on that note uh thank you very much
all
i hope that webinar will be
well appreciated and if you have any
questions we have these
contact and these support and key
phone number thank you very much